bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale télé
spéciale championnat du monde d'échecs
âne en versus
topalov avec le maître fide et
jean-jacques rabeyrin joue c'est fun
alors tu nous avais dit accompagné sur
la cinquième si on va revoir nos deux
protagonistes avec cette fois un hand
dans la sixième partie dont camille
match avec les blancs et on sait que
pour l'instant à ce moment du match il a
gagné ses deux parties avec les blancs
ce2 catalan bien joué effectivement pour
le moment deux victoires condé catalan
alors jamais deux sans trois on va voir
donc on peut s'attendre une catalane
donc en or ce qui était intéressant de
ce match comme on l'avait déjà dit ou qu
on le redira souvent sur l'émission ce
qui n'était à ça c'est que les joueurs
il en bon père sévère dans les
ouvertures qui leur donne des avantages
et c'est d'éviter celles qui l'ont vu
perdre on voir
risquer de perdre en tout cas afin de ne
pas donner des bâtons pour se faire
battre à l'adversaire évidemment donc là
anne on a gagné le dos avec la catalane
donc qu'il va rejouer la catalane et
topalov insiste lui aussi sait peut-être
peut-être mais qui sait pas jouer autre
chose je sais pas c'est vrai que de
topalov alors je sais pas s'il ne suit
pas question ses résultats sur les katas
sur la can j'ai parlé à l'esthétique
très bon et à contrer kramnik j'ai
souvenir qu'il est perdu quand le crâne
il n'avait souffert il avait perdu une
ktm concrètement c'est une partie du
match aller quasiment indécelable
beaucoup c'est ça oui mais enfin topalov
cramique et kramnik topalov fils et
cramique avait gagné oui dès lors
c'était catalan il est parti un peu
tragique parce que c'était plutôt
topalov qui était archi gagnant et oui
il faisait des dégâts et qui avait gaffé
krainik avait fini par baisser le poids
mais ces gars là aussi même s'il a fait
des gaffes c'est pas à l'aise c'est que
c'est une position qui est dans laquelle
il est balèze il a du mal à jouer
d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans la première
les deux piétonnes qui ont joué jusqu'à
présent sont pas les mêmes c'est à dire
la première annonce d'un jouet une
ouverture fin une nouveauté qui va
personnellement de ma palais saint
ambroise et ça effectivement damas trois
problèmes ans il n'y a aucun avantage
pour les blancs là dessus et les joueurs
gardent le reconnaître en plus après
ouais ouais ouais en conférence de
presse ce bar est pas très convaincant
mais après il n'y a pas su hollande a
complètement dominé son adversaire dans
donc c'est une position qui doit pas
savoir très bien à qui sera ya des
positions n'est pas forcément moins bien
mais si on n'a pas l'habitude de la
traiter on connaît pas les laits
finalement il était mais la façon de la
jouer
alors on va voir ça allende à les blancs
contre topalov parti numéro 6 on est à
mi match alain domaine de deux points
non deux points et donc moment crucial
toujours du match on y va me match
puisqu'après un an aura de nouveau les
blancs dans la septième donc d4
qu'alexis c4e 6k relief 3d 5 et la
catalane avec g3 voilà ça y est on allé
reparti pour un tour
donc c'est pour jouer le coup j'ai deux
pour un an d
mais topalov prendre l'option ces quatre
fous j'ai 2 à 6 donc on a déjà commenté
un petit peu cette ouverture dans l'est
dans les précédentes donc on va
peut-être pas y revenir à chaque fois je
vous invite à avoir les les commentaires
des diagonales tv spéciale parti numéro
2 et 4 du championnat du monde où on
avait les blancs aussi intéressant c'est
que là il joue la partie numéro 2 et
mais pas la partie numéro 4 une partie
numéro 4 il avait dévié avant pour une
ligne qui est normalement
par ici les bonnes effectivement et là
il reprend la partie numéro 2 qui comme
on l'a dit au début avait s'était plutôt
bien passé pour topalov au stade de
l'ouverture mais qui s'est très mal
passé par la suite
donc la c5 est calé à 3 celle apparue la
première la fin la numéro deux la
deuxième c'est ça oui la halle
non là oui c'est ça là on a 4 2 1 en
seizièmes avec les blancs non la partie
lors des deux matches nuls au dos il
revient à l'aérogare l'a4 il s'est fait
topalov s'est fait un peu mal à écrire
ouais ouais il revient à celle où ils
avaient une position aux sorties de
l'ouverture tout à fait honorable mais
qu'il est perdu par la suite c'est
prendre les quatre donc là ils
choisissent et prend des claques donc la
quitte et bien c'est c5 qui dévie aussi
parce que là il
il a joué ces saignements dans les
nominés dans les deux dauphines non il
ya une partie est passé où il a joué
dans l'a4 que les jouets poupées car la
fougue et quatre échecs
voilà mais c'est d'aider à 6 ans fait
que qui varient cfoot des 4 as we à
saint-louis la veille a réussi à hisser
sa surprise des foulées quatre fous d2
et a5 avec l'histoire de pions ici qui
s'était affecté au et une pression sur
les pions avant c'est donc la c1 une
autre variante avec à 6 mai sur le
sérieux 5 ces cinq attaques des quatre
cavaliers à 3 donc là l'idée évidemment
c'est d'aller reprendre en c4 évidemment
b5 est impossible toujours à cause du
fou j'ai deux magnifiques fou voilà qui
attaquent la tour donc c'est prendre 4
et les blancs en fait sacrifie deux
pions parce qu'ils ont donné deux pions
l'option sekkat le plan des cadres est
en fait un sacrifice de pions
positionnelle à cesser la catalane s'est
on a un coût monstrueux le fou j'ai deux
foulées de qui est énorme et pour ça on
accepte de donner un pion central quand
même absent tu rames et isoler un peu
mais oui oui il faut il pas facile à les
pions pour soutenir sont bloqués voilée
il ya toujours grosse pression sur
bessède sur ses six les dépressions sont
les cases là partout sur la ceca ce
cavalier qui peut remplacer un aussi bon
bref fous ces cinq petit rock petit rock
et là on est exactement dans la partie
numéro 2 voilà et là il avait joué fou
d2 et donc la londe avait joué fou d2 et
donc avec une partie qu'il a finalement
gagné mais
convaincante mais pas très convaincante
alors là il change donc il a estimé j'ai
gagné mais je peux faire mieux la
prochaine fois j'essaierai de faire
mieux j'ai gagné mais j'essaierai de
faire mieux il fait foulée 5
bref tout porte à penser que dans la dot
dans la partie numéro 2 où il avait
égalisé tout porte à penser que oui
topaloff avait fait des tas de petites
imprécisions on peut penser qu'à la
maison il les a et les aot visionner
améliorée et que les canons ne se
sentait pas de leur porte sur ce terrain
là donc là on reste cinquième volet 5
alors à noter ici que les noirs ou en
courbe naturelle sans doute qui est de
jouer qu'à aller mais les sept ça on a
envie de même bien je vais l'écart est
comme ça alors ça si ça se heurte pas
simplement cavaliers prend des cercles
voilà puisque sur fou prend évidemment
il ya flambé cette attaque la tour et
sur dame prend 17 on pourrait envisager
de prendre le cas les six avec un
doublage de pions si envisageable oui
c'est c'est chaud parce que ça fait
beaucoup de pions enceinte pour les
noirs bon alors ceci dit tant pas
l'ajout h 6/4 en limite les choix de
goûts et les couleurs h6 attaque le fou
des scènes qui n'a pas eu d'impact de
sortie puisque 1 h 4 ans moi qu'il est
bloqué par le curage 3 donc sur h4 g5 et
le fou est perdu voilà
on peut on peu dénudée un peu le roi
pour une pièce parce que finalement les
noirs vont pouvoir venir protéger leurs
droits facilement donc ya pas deux il
n'y a pas de vrai problème on perdrait
une vraie pièce il faut absolument de
toute façon on va pas revenir en d2
parce que sinon jouer tout de suite
donc on prend donc le hollandais en
viager 5e c'est dans l'idée de prendre
oui oui je besoin on peut supposer que
c'était sa préparation
lui qui va préparer tout j'ai saric il
ya forcément prévu à chis voilà donc
dans prend 1,6
bon c'est fort c'est on va par contre dû
plonger une adresse qu on a le pion à
chiètres fr le cavalier g4 derrière
c'est surtout que lecavalier où il déjà
à la base il est prévu pour revenir au
des trois cavaliers en plus en d3 il
peut venir en d3 la dame venir en d2
attaqué à jets en effectivement surpris
du pur il avait peut-être pas en d3 mais
sur une case plus avantageuse donc d'un
cran m6 voilà car les détroits donc la
voir les lecavalier magnifique parce que
ils bloquent le pion des cas donc ces
unions bloqueurs il attaque le fou c'est
il permet son collègue pourquoi pas de
le remplacer le 5
c'est une possibilité j'ai dit on parce
que les mine de rien les blancs quand
même déjà concédé la paire de fou oui
leurs adversaires et option est un pion
mais en échange de quoi ils ont déjà un
fini leur développement alors que les
noms et les noirs il reste pas mal de
monde à la maison il ya deux pièces
vraiment bloqué à tord aussi alors que
les blancs sont déjà un possibilité de
bouger leur tour alors face est bon très
bien le foot reste en soutiennent de son
pion des quatre mais c'est un faux
passif du coup hein parce qu'ils sont
rayon d'action et bloquer votre pion des
cartes dont les blancs se sert
finalement comme pivot en fait
finalement pour leurs cavaliers ce pion
et pour empêcher les noirs finalement de
faire des pressions sur cette colonne
damas quatre tranquille alors à noter
sur damas quatre et dont on a envie de
jouer les simples puisque on se dit
tiens fourchette de suite c'est le coût
qui vient à l'esprit tout de suite mais
mais mais regardez le fou attaquent la
turquie suffirait d'enlever la dame
ici par exemple en c2 et sur b prince et
4 ont fait simplement dame prend ses 4
et lé noir perdent la torah 8 il n'y a
pas de défense et je veux surtout me
reprendre le bureau c4 parce que si on
se presse trop et on prend les atours
valet noir reprennent le deuxième
cavaliers bien sûr oui
ah oui oui il faudrait pas évidemment
prendre la tour tout de suite ici avec
le fou puisque les noirs prendrait ici
et on aurait gagné deux pièces alors que
dans simplement d'emprunt c4 ici et là
tour est perdu alors on pourrait sauver
la tour parquet laissait 6 mai aura la
pièce et on a donné un pion
effectivement bon donc qu'on fait pas ça
donc damas quatre cas les c6 voilà qui
est une autre variante l'avait alors les
noirs sont prêts à donner un pion mais
contre le fu g2 le chou blanc il est la
fierté de tout joueur catalan il faut il
va pas le donner oui parce que si je le
donnerai ici qu'est ce qui va se passer
après b prend
dans prend ses se fout là qui va être
énorme on va jouer autour des 8 par
exemple et après fou 17 et là où il y
avait plus roi qu'elle a une dame qui va
pouvoir
tôt ou tard je ne sais pas par exemple
se recycler en des 8es en d5 et ses
maths alors je vais vite mais disons que
pour les pour que les blancs part ça il
va falloir jouer des coups comme f3 kiev
qui sont affaiblis sang etc
et c'est donc le flou sera très fort en
tout cas donc on fait certainement pas
ça en donne pas ce qu'on fout qui est à
la fois un kung-fu d'attaqué en foot
défense du duo blanc qu'elles
nécessiteront joue plus simple tour à
ces jeunes tranquille c'est bien ça
coûte développement voilà coûts de
développement normal on prend la colonne
c'est donc là les noirs jouent eux sec
intéressant contrôle évidemment leurs
pions des quatre avec le pion
c'est bon ça c'était peut-être pas le
thème évident mais surtout libère le
fossé vite on va pouvoir sortir certains
n'ont par exemple réussissent voir un
riff cents pas mal en 1500 pour attaquer
le cabinet 3 6e foot attaqué en plus
pour à se recycler en chaussettes il
sera bien placé c'est une possibilité
voilà donc que 5 pour libérer le fossé
vite je pense qu'on peut bien pour lui
elle fut séduite et oui oui oui ou non
il faut faire quelque chose
mais voilà le problème c'est que ça
donne un pion c'est ça ça donne un pur
ou alors ça donne un pion ça donne
presque deux pions en fait voilà donc ça
va donner un pion aux blancs ça donne un
pion mais pour le pour le fou le flou g2
qu'on n'a pas envie de donner
voilà mais est-ce que si on veut voilà
ce que l'idée d'un deuxième c'est qu'il
ya des deux cavaliers évidemment ici
voiliers qui attaquent le cavaly c6 qui
protège elana on peut éliminer le
défenseur et sur b prend bien on se
venge champions en scène puis pourquoi
pas le pion c6 qui est faible aussi
ça va faire deux pions on en a fait un
de moins on en a même plus mais on en a
la paire de faux compte renouer un roi
qui est un peu affaibli effectivement
effectivement alors on y va donc défaut
c'est ce que faire d'un fou prend ses 6
or là curieusement c'est curieux quand
même parce qu'alors donc il joue il joue
mais cinq
notre avis topalov il joue pas les
processus carrière pourtant évident
voire même d'un processus pourquoi pas
mais des princes et 6 cas l'air d'être
le coup à l'horizon qui se heurterait a
sans doute cavale et ses princes cheiks
attaque c6 qui est pas évident à
défendre bon mais qu à wallers avait
largement pour les noirs st alors pardon
parce que sauf au prince et six topalov
renouf et b5
ils ont sept au lieu de lieu de
reprendre ses 6 mai reprenant ses 6 avec
un pion on n'a pas forcément envie parce
que ce pur ans et il sera faible
oui mais on joue en bessin qu'est-ce
qu'on ne permet pas aux blancs de garder
la même idée de faire ah oui il faut
prendre des cinq accords mais l'idée
aussi ont fait faux grand mécène qui ont
compté 5 dimpre en bessin il ya eu 4 à
la fin avec un gros centre de pions la
paire de fou et donc est donc une grosse
attaque sur laurent blanc est comme ça
ça va être très dangereux ça c'est pas
jouable c'est très difficile et b 5 mai
donc
ouais c'est quand même bizarre parce que
b5 bon alors il joué à nantes joue dame
c2 et là on reprendre la dame
tranquillement et en fait l'intérêt de
l'intérêt dames cécile d'hazard
bessengue effectivement on prendre la
dame
un accord aurait donc c'est malin en
fait j'y joue dessins qu'ils incitent
les blancs à prendre ici ce qui serait
une mauvaise affaire puisque les noirs
ont une très forte initiative avec le 4
et les blancs sont en fait objet d'un mc
do et on prend avec la dame et on
voulait pas échanger les dames en fait
on ne veut pas échanger les dames et
laval on a donné le football on est là
il ya la grosse diagonale blanche
convient de prendre avec la dame tu as
fais tout à fait donc là à regarder la
dame attaque sur cette grande diagonale
et on a bien envie de jouer quoi
troubler cette info b cette dame là et
hop et en maths en g2 ou en achat alors
évidemment les blancs laisse pas faire
ça à eux de jouer il joue cavalier
princen on récupère que l'option voilà
et ont très simplement on récupère un
pion en plus sont en cavale et qui va
pouvoir éventuelles sur le client est
roi ainsi a besoin de sa bouche la
nationale on peut aussi jouer le 3 je
pense que c'est pas très grave deux
jours et fait 3 1 puisque le pion de d4
et les blocs et il n'y a pas de problème
avec le x 7 contre le roi et la dame sur
toute attaque est évidemment un échange
des dames arrangerait les blancs puisque
là on a rendu le pion avec les noix on
se retrouve au final avec un pion faible
capture des quatre cas isolé le pire des
cas très faible le pieux qui qui bouche
aussi l'action du fou à 7 qui est un peu
passif quand même il est uniquement
défenseur et un échange des dames
arrangerait les blancs on est d'accord
là dessus
oui oui on peut dire ça je pense qu'on
peut dire ça disons un échange informel
et non mais surtout topalov encore des
désespoirs d'attac d'attac on va dire
alors qui veut pas changer d'avion qui
veut pas échangé la wii alors il vous
donne 4 voilà on a me 4 évidemment on
peut pas à sortir le cavalier pour
proposer un échange et dames puisque le
cavalier s'inquiètant pris les 2 qui
avait se protègent mutuellement et on va
menacer fou bessette qui est question
mais qui est quand même menace maths
alors ça ça forcera f3 mais qui a fait
mille drôlement voie qui n'est pas le
jouer elle n'était pas agréable parce
qu'on crée des trous et on va pouvoir
attaquer ce rock qui s'affaiblit on va
jouer à 5 h 4 pourquoi pas f5 aussi
pourquoi pas j'ai cinq pour jouer gilles
latapie sur f3 alors un échec pour nos
trois en or un échec en e3 on pourrait
attaquer les cavaliers par exemple les
tarifs 6 mois plus tôt avec la tour même
avec le dos de l'arrière avec une tour
avec 2 qui tape derrière on fait
beaucoup de choses donc là les blancs
mais empêche cette manoeuvre parle et
parle évident dame c6 voilà bon mais
très bien même ces 6 alors en plus sa
force échange de dames puisque là la
dame a pas trop le choix si la dame s'en
relève de l' échange par exemple par f5
et bien c'est la torah 8 qui prend et ça
c'est pas bon avec catastrophe donc il
faut pas donc topal avoue un joli coup
plutôt que deux
on prend pas évidemment c'est si ce qui
permettrait cavaler brand qui menacerait
de prendre le x 7 et donc l'on dirait on
pourrait dire que le pion des 4 x aurait
condamné puisqu'il y aura plus défenseur
on pourrait le pylône et ce pion et
isolées très difficile à défendre donc
foulé cette taupe à la poêle à noter
très jolie développement bad et le fouet
la dalle se protègent malgré que la dame
blanche soit un milieu bien non si l'on
prend le soin en l'autre et à chaque
fois il ya une défense mutuelle à
travers
j'ai envie de dire l'attaquant
effectivement voilà donc c'est joli ça
très joli coup de développement alors on
veut dire dams et si c'était qu'elle ait
beaucoup forcer parce que oui il fallait
absolument en question il faut l'espérer
mais on va quand même je fous baisser
sans affaiblir f3 est possible alors ça
a fait but principal c'est quand même
pas joli willems et si c'est forcé mais
à la fois très bon à la fois très bon et
donc faut baisser depuis pour protéger
les la bafoue bessette et donc on est
champions vont finalement ont fini par
échanger dame
mais si on compare avec la position
qu'on
regardez il ya quelque temps on s'est
demandé si on pouvait pas y changer
d'âme mais le fou il céderait il s'est
développé et mis gratuite de façon
gratuite
henri iv plutôt que de rester ans et 8
c'est beaucoup mieux donc c'est quand
même nettement mieux pour les noirs qui
ont privé une pièce en position
intéressante de finale alors qu est-ce
qu on peut noter alors les blancs ont
repris leur viande - saison les noirs on
sacrifie ont dû sacrifier leurs pions
pour libérer leur fou sinon il était un
peu un peu à la ramasse
voilà donc la ici ils ont ils ont alors
ils ont la paire de fou quand même les
noirs mais en échange de quoi belle et
blanc ont deux atouts ont ils ont un
pion des quatre isolé qui peut faire
l'objet d'une cible en finale
imaginez si les tours ces changements
mais elle aura blanc petit à petit il va
venir en d3 libre et c'est empêcher le
fond blanc de faire des échecs et
essayer de gommer le pion par karine f3
cavale et prendre les quatre est un gros
plus en plus ça peut être ça suffit pour
une décisif en finale
et puis ils ont la colonne s'est il on
la connaît et on verra pas ce qu'elle
est quand même la cgt eaux loir de jouer
pour la contester tout en essayant de
lancer aux blancs et même les blancs ils
apprennent ils n'apprennent quand même
pour ces deux prennent la colonne donc
tour ces deux tours et fuites donc
l'attention une menace noir ça pourrait
de faire tout reprend cavaliers
cavaliers pro tour et il faut prendre
pourront évidemment bien celui d'yvon
menace a menacé voilà ton prend
cavaliers qui gagne une pièce puisque
car les pro tour et repris par faut
prendre tout donc on protège et tours 8
millions finalement on aurait pu essayer
de contester la colonne s'aimer les uns
les blancs redoublé l'on rénové de la
façon
on aurait été acquise aux blancs mêmes
raisons mais rien en défense il vaut
mieux garder les deux tours des mines et
plus on échange de tours plus brillante
des cadres va être faible est ce qu'on
peut imaginer même sans aucune pièce la
finale de rang avec difficile parce que
ce qu on va être un peu isolé bon je
pense ça peut tenir quand même mais ça
va être difficile
la paire de fou qu'on pense quand même
bien la paire de faux composant leur
pour l'instant la paire de fou comprends
qu'on pense alors à noter aussi que la
tour 8 non seulement attaque le cavalier
hossein mais aussi fait une petite
pression sur eux deux ce qui n'est pas
rien c'est un petit pion fait bon pour
l'équipe après faible à elle la
trotteuse on peut imaginer que le roi
blanc viennent en f1 bon mais il faut
quand même tenir compte f6 donc tour
c'est un oui ça pour la vie mais c'est
apparaît ça va ça paraît la menace qu
est-ce que tout reprendre marche plus
parce qu'avant tout reprend ankama les
princes vous prend vous reprend et bilan
des courses elle a échangé des pièces ce
qui est favorable aux blancs mais
surtout on a le cas c'est la paire de
fou on a cassé la paire de fois de
bernard il ya plus qu'un seul fou il a
le pire des cas de va devenir de plus en
plus un gros problème
voilà le petit on est quatrième
devient un vrai souci devient la cible
privilégiée des blancs alors là les
noirs mais chasse ce cavalier 1,5 qui
est quand même fini et on l'a on va voir
un ballet équestre
c'est à dire une navigation de cavaliers
d'un land magnifique magnifique coup
puisqu'on voir une série je crois de
sept coups de cavaliers alors je crois
que c'est 13 13 coût
alors on va voir alors on va voir on va
voir le pouf calais 17
bon alors évidemment ce cavalier temps
17 peut venir en c5 attaque elle fout il
peut aussi aider la tour à venir ans et
7 puisque du coup le fou ne peut pas
regarder en baie vitrée en c6 ce
cavalier magnifique il protège les
cannes il est superbe ce cavalier en
17.5 de la part ici des noirs alors là
je me suis demandé pourquoi les blancs
ici ne ne joue pas tous et c'est tout
simplement parce que tout simplement
tourcoing 2 voilà comme ça c'est réglé
c'est ce qu'on disait s'éclate au aussi
attaque le pion voilà donc cavale et 7
ici en c5
alors ici les noirs pourrait prendre le
fou c'est sec d'accord et surtout
reprendre ses scènes jouées 3 de
récupération mais il ya le four les
trois points et c'est moi ça marche pas
tout simplement à cause de cette
manoeuvre donc quelle est cette c5
s'explique donc foulée 6 pour protéger
de pure et 6 qui étaient arrêtés
oui parce qu'alors fou b6 protège le
pion à 6 par la tour avant que avant
tout mais si c'est évidemment le pion à
6 était en prise du cavalier voilà donc
cavaler baisse est donc ça fait le 1 2
3e coup de cavaliers menace l'impression
qu'à nantes est en train de d'essayer de
rendre fou topalov à c'est un ballet de
cavaliers d'extérieur les matches on
regarde là la position blanche elle est
difficile améliorée entre guillemets
parce que les deux tours sont très bien
placés sont passées de façon optimale
pas trop comment les bouger ne peuvent
pas pénétrer l ont pas vraiment d'entrée
à cause des défauts qui défoule les
cases c'est un peu pénible la paire de
foot c est quand même fort et la
structure de pion est très bonne et tout
pousse et affaiblir et plus ou moins la
plus juste peut-être le pion aux deux
qui est faible allure au dos on peut pas
le pousser parce que l on peut pas le
pousser à lloret prises avec un fou mais
si ces normes qui vise le roi blanc
derrière en queue de peloton on peut pas
avoir le pousser et enjouée roi et enfin
bref wait commencer ou h3oz trois chiens
huawei et il y aurait fort à 5 aussi
alors ça serait faux g4 est donc donc
finalement toutes les piles toutes les
toutous les seules pièces vraiment
jouable disponible entre la joie bhl
disponible chez les cavaliers et on va
voir qui va les manoeuvres et
magnifiquement alors là l'hymne hassan
en cavale et des six attaques tour 8 est
fou échec
donc on en est où 1 2 3 on menace on est
troisième coup de cavaliers donc fou dès
cette quatrième coup là c'est le
deuxième bourrin qui vient à la
rescousse alors un incroyable
il veut il veut venir sans doute en d5
commencé à titiller le fou le fourbe et
6,1 à 6,6 alors il va échanger un des
fous est par exemple le fou de cases
noires et après on peut pénétrer ans et
7 avec un avantage a donc il faut faire
travailler il ya deux choses si la paire
de shoes comme on l'a dit ça contrôle
d'état de casey c'est vraiment un
avantage mais à partir du moment où il
disparaît en perte d'avantagés il reste
plus que la faiblesse était déjà à la
traque lancée position un peu égal parce
qu'il ya vraiment un avantage de
matériel on va dire le côté noir sceller
les deux fous et une faiblesse
structurelle qui est le pion des 4 donc
si on perd la paire de fou ça ça va dire
pour l'avoir donc tout rabais 8
maintenant attaque donc le cavalier qui
est un peu pénible qu'est ce qu'ils
demandent ce qu'ils aimaient faire la
queue à l'aider si c'est la regarder
c'est très joli ce qui va suivre en
année ça c'était le cinquième coûte
cavaliers tours sec donc là attention
oui parce que la tour donc été calé
attaqué par ce cavalier donc y trouve
une jolie quasi si bon ben c'est simple
il faut dire qu'il n'a pas forcément des
mains sein des classes et kbc 8
ça fait le sixième coup 6e coup de
cavaliers toujours le même nom qui est
le nom des sept îles et bien c'est
simple j'ai un bep satimo non décisive
et ensuite ils savent qu'ils ont dirait
calanques s'amuse ses cavaliers là alors
travailler et henry samuel mais il ya
aussi une grosse composante dans la
position cécile a cassé cette les
les blancs ont envie de rentrer ancêtres
avaient là ils veulent prendre le foot
b6 évidemment et pénétrer ans et 7 avec
avantage la colonne ouverte c'est pas
rien c'est pas c'est pas négligeable
imaginons que après les blancs arrive à
jouer tour à sept et tour bbc set on a
deux tours sur la septième avec des
menaces très très forte voire même
gagnante contrôler notre donc faut
éviter absolument ça donc c'est pour
c'est pourquoi
topalov joue fou à 5 et la cavaliers
detroit alors moi j'avais cru quand j'ai
regardé la partie qui jouer qu'à les
droits pour attaquer la tour ça c'est
une chose dans sa saisie de ces think we
have alliés donc hélas avec l'idée que
lecavalier en fait protéger et donc je
jouais b4 et le fou il a du mal
maintenant trouver des gars plus que des
villes comme cannes il ya plus que des 8
mai ça suffit et je pense qu'il ya ça
suffit ça suffit ça suffit quand même
alors qu'à avaler des trois tours vie
m'ont déjà on peut pas jouer mais pas
tout de suite à cause du cavalier c8 qui
est attaqué alors là non de jouer un
coup peut être sa mère son huitième coup
de cali c'est incroyable 8e coup de
cavaliers pourront alors là en fait sans
doute il fallait revenir en d6 il joue
cavalier à 7 qui n'est pas acquis et pas
forcément le meilleur
alors c'est un peu difficile à dire les
joueurs catalan adore mettre camion c6
c'est peut-être reinhardt et ses
réflexes
il veut le mettre là il m'a bien si la
rhyolite là c'est très bien et une
fourchette tourbe et 8 x 5 c très bien
ça obligerait les le food assez changé
et il va arriver il va arriver en c6
on peut pas vraiment la revue charles
empêcherait donc floue mais 6 de taux
par la banque qui évite déjà qui ne
fonctionne en cavale et c6 est tombé
cette île veut pas échanger c'est fou il
veut pas à faire comprendre les
cavaliers donc en était à l heure où la
neuvième bout de quartier on peut se
poser quelques questions parce que parce
que là le le le
on aurait pu prendre ce fou ce que les
alliés partent alors là voilà alors
qu'est ce qui se passe si alors bon tour
prend pas ce qu est un pion deux et on a
toujours le pion à 2 qui en l'air bien
sûr donc la corée fait est donc enfin
donc là effectivement topalov aurait pu
abandonner sa paire de fou mais quand
même avec bien d'un pion gagnent un pion
mais il est dans une finale on se
foutait pas bon à cause du clan des 4 1
c'est quelle salle il est tout
simplement la ligne toujours pas il est
blanc contre comme la colonne c'est le
fouillent peux pas trop bouger parce que
légal qui aura six derrière il est
embêté par le pion est là que se
serait-il passé sur un hérisson
attendait 6 non je pense pas mal de
marge
je pense déjà qu'il aurait joué un roi
et fin par exemple au fn ayant attaqué
la tour dans ce cas là autour des
données possibles attaques en cavalier
alors tour d2 est possible la seule
chose qu'il faut réaliser fait qu'il
faut réaliser n'est pas trop tard c'est
aussi dans une position c'est qu'on peut
pas prendre les cailles gestion pour le
cavalier 3e 2e et la tour est perdu
la tour est perdu et puisque s'imaginant
que les blancs jouent un bateau des six
par exemple surtout refrain des trois
rondes et la torah pas de gaz tout est
pris c'est ça faut le voir parce que
évidemment c'est le coût de ces le coup
de jarnac on risque de ne pas voir 1,8
ce si on joue une partie en blitz well
as que je pense que eux mêmes angles
itil le voir et en missiles de voix
alors bon c'était possible alors c'était
possible mais ça doit boire après on a
incurvé
on n'était pas obligé de venir en d2
avec la tour on peut revenir bon
regarder une prise de pionsat se regarde
pas forcément donc l'assurerait f1 chez
pas la tour aurait pu repartir alors ce
roi f1 ici la tortue
venir par exemple 00h08 mais on se dit
quand même que ça va ça devrait passer
pour l'épauler beau parce que genre par
exemple cavaliers p4 qui attaquent le
pion calais b quatre attaques à 6 et
ensuite on a joué au cahier des cinq
sens un baassiste
oui oui car il faisait 5 probablement
qu'ils avaient des syndicats et des cinq
attaques le fou valff où il va s'y vend
à cette tombe et ses tours ses sept
il ya toujours la célèbre entre ses
soeurs ça fait peur quand donc six
volets suivants des 8
voilà maintenant je pense qu'il suffit
de d'attaquer le pion des cages fait
d'appeler d'attaqué se tient et on le
récupère mais bon est-ce qu on
al'avantage c'est pas sûr en a quand
même des tours haptique bon le fonds est
mal placé il est pas très actif il est
pas donc j'ai enfin je sais pas si on me
regarde on ne la réduisent réparé le
terrier bon sens va plus loin avec les
allées bk et des cadres donc attaque à
si on prend surtout s'il ya pas le choix
quand on pousse on peut pas mettre la
tour qu'avait les dessins donc la foux à
7 ou food & vie aia que y'a que fout des
huîtres et moules au début et par
exemple vous tour cédé hors dé 1 il
récupère le cuir et on est très bien
avec un cave et des incas valais central
mais est-ce que c'est suffisant baja
n'ira c'est quand même fou qui est vrai
qu'il y paraît pas très bon et normal le
fou est complètement dominés et demi
il ya dominé peut pas il n'y a pas de
case il n'y a pas de 15 c'est vrai que
kara les dom il nous faudrait regarder
comme c'est magnifique le cavalier ici
effectivement domine le four à toutes
les cases du fou sont prises par le
cavalier donc c'est quand même pénible
et les blancs ont récupéré deux tons des
4es
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont ils ont de
l'activité alors est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour prendre un avantage c'est
pas sûr mais celle de la position énorme
passing et donc qu'on n'a pas envie de
jouer avec donc c'est peut-être pour ça
donc c'est sûrement pour ça que topalov
on n'a pas pris voilà que je tombe et
scène alors faire ne pas prendre et
garder la paire de fois par contre on
peut se payer une peut-être une autre
qui est chose stéphane c'est parce que
là que c'est le lecavalier il vient de
c'est son huitième coup là qu'il vient
de masse de glace et l'a7
on a attaqué avec le foot b6 ouais mais
en fait ce cavalier on voit qu'il va
vous sinon la tacc convoi qui ne peut
venir que en c6
on aurait pu l'attaquer et peut-être
plutôt de l'attaqué que le full attack
est que la tour donc finalement on va
voir à peu près la même genre là même où
tour alors tomber cette pas forcément
parce qu'il aura le lac à la casse et 8
mai tour habite à ouidah cause alors tu
auras 8 wemmel est mal placé la tour et
ben c'est pas du tout clair parce que la
marque a laissé six essais ci et là on
prend de nouveaux emprunts tours troyes
et tours pro a et maintenant on prend le
2 alors dans la même position que tout à
l'heure
apparaissant thaler sous contrôle
oui à part que tout à l'heure on avait
la tour b 8 et le fou en b 4 le fou un
saint qui paraît déjà légèrement mieux
placé si contrôle quand même des choses
sur la diagonale mais peut se faire
chasser par des quatre noms et en plus
y'a plus le clouage puisqu'après le fou
il pouvait pas bouger
le soldat curatives il retourne en
d'élite ainsi vendée vite on va jouer
tous ses mythes
c'est embêtant quand même s'il vient des
huit se fout on joue on joue un tour ses
huit attaques la tour donc il faut
prendre pour prendre pour un menace de
prendre le fou avec échec donc tour 8
force est alors vendu en plus des 4 b 4
par l'enjeu pour sur b4 on ne bouge pas
voilà on joue faut jouer autour des 2
sur 9 et 4 rouges autour des joueurs de
talent en attaque et on attaque le
cavalier voilà c'est ça et là dans ce
cas là sur qui on prend 1 5% car il est
si calais bouge on prend on prend le nom
des quatre villas on est très très très
bon et une autre option ben c'est une
option qui parraine limite ne peut plus
intéressante parce que là on prend un
pion enfin on a vu une position où on
prenait le pion quand on essuie son
premier pion oui et puis ça justifierait
le fait que ce coup cavaliers à cette
part est bizarre le mètre carré à la
borne comme ça qui n'a qu'une caste
sortie ça paraît pas forcément le
meilleur coût les quotidiens c6 on va
prendre on donc on lâche la paire de
flou pour prendre 2 et après ils quelle
est la meilleure position donc on peut
l'obtenir soit avec le fouetter mien à 5
le foot est un soap l'obtenir avec le
fourbe et si la tour en belgique ce soit
cela qui vous fait à soi tout le monde
se rassure tout le monde sur b et tout
le monde si on baissa pareil largement
préférable mais ne serait-ce que avec la
petite arnaque qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
qui était jean record la tour vient en
d2 way qui attaquent le cavalier ouais
ouais
le cavalier peut pas bouger parce que
sinon on prendrait b2 mais le problème
c'est que on a dit lecavalier pas
prenable parce que sinon il ya eu après
roy après roy et vahirua ou deux qui
gagne la tour en f1 ici et qui prenait
natori siwel que font un sacré c'est pas
ça marche plus d'essence à marge plus ça
marche plus parce que la tour toujours
la casse des deux est au 8 août a fait
peut-être d'entre eux notre analyse
rapide donc peut-être tour habite au
lieu de foot b6 voilà comme quoi une
petite précision est pas évidente à voir
hors jeu s'est passé mais au moins on
prend un pion et puis
puis puis on voit peut-être plus facile
pour les vendre à un autocar donc fauves
et si ce qu'a laissé six tours 17 voilà
donc c'est en été au huitième coup de
cavaliers lorsqu'ils vont à ces deux
partis s'ils écoutent carrier donc 9e
coup quelques idées quatre de suite cg
oui que quelqu'un l'avait fait rare les
parties où il ya autant de coups de
cavaliers de suite à celle maintenant
pour les noirs bon il y avait l'idée sol
un call et des scènes donc à un dizième
coup comme ça donc 10e coup et la bombe
et la drac en photo alors il va lâcher
son fou elle alla peuvent avoir les
lélés les leaders du jouet encore floues
déclin alors non parce qu'il ya qu a
réalisé 5 ski doo de soissons va prendre
à voilà il ya le deuxième cas liquidant
ses cinq attaques ça y est c'est fini
voilà la paire de fou il ya bien sûr la
perte de fouilles gagner bien sûr après
calais b 4
la menace est calé ses cinq ans fait
tout de suite non seulement à six et
attaquer mais aussi qu'elle et ses
scènes dans l'air d'accord donc avaler
donc à six qui avaient des 5 et là on
sait pas trop où se retirer mais on n'y
a pas vraiment de bonnes cases
on pourrait aussi essayer de dents le
visage de petit fou à 7 mai la saga
s'agace c'est cette voie là là là on
lâche
oui on peut jouer pour ces fêtes
peut-être oui mais c'est sûr on peut
jouer tous et c'est très fort et cet
effort c'est quand même pénible parce
que surtout reprend 1,3 et il ya un fou
qui font qu'ils disent pas rien alors
doublé tour mais de toute façon ça fait
longtemps que le four est sûre sur la
diagonale rappelé 1,5 pour les noirs
pour les noirs c'est à dire que tu veux
dire ici sur ici surtout à 7 pour ses
sets tu voulais dire on peut jouer ça
c'est ça oui oui mais il doit y avoir
des astuces non non pas donc on peut
prendre une fois joué cavalier qui avait
laissé sa raquette façon dont leurs
ouvert on va gagner si on peut prendre
une fois évoqué les c5
oui oui on peut prendre une fois je vous
tiens blessés scène tout à fait tout
reprend et calais c5
voilà récupère un faux puisqu'on peut
pas jouer pour ces sept corps était le
coup intéressant il ya le câble et des
scènes donc l' attaque et bien il faut
il faut prendre faut prendre et là
la lequel le pion des 4 va commencer à
se voir ah oui nice voilà il voit très
bien une en d4
mais c'est vrai qu'il est l'idée a été
lancée une cible c'est clairement une
cible et si les blancs le prenne mais
ils auront plus en plus rare d anacarde
physique entre 3 donc là ça pourrait ça
pourrait s'avérer décisif alors bon on
va revenir donc à notre nouveau coup de
cavaliers dont qui a quatre et là ça y
est 10e coup 11e coup
il prend un défaut c'est quand même une
belle manoeuvre conséquente et
cavalières effectivement je pas facile à
voir les subtilités de ce qui a pu se
passer
l'activité des cavaliers était forte
mais les fous sont forts aussi on a vu
même même sur un petit périmètre
contrôlé beaucoup de cases et on voulait
pas il n'y a pas eu de combinaisons
vraiment crucial au nom s'était plus
hissé les luttes de fou pour lui de
cavaliers dans une position typiques des
finales alors ici donc tout reprendre et
alors oui là là on peut se demander
pourquoi avec un tour pareil elle pion
au tour pareille structure là on se
demande depuis le début pourquoi ils
ramènent pas son endroit où ça en finale
puisque on a souvent envie de ramener le
roi
hélas non ou alors même d'un coup comme
le roi ya quand même trois roues en f2
court depuis trop visage à bhl ne le
fait pas alors car elle et ses cinq donc
attaquer le fou et 7
là là là maintenant une fois que le fou
quasiment disparu est bon un jour ce
coup là il hiberne aussi la colonne des
il va pouvoir commencer à faire pression
sur ce point alors ce qui va se passer
c'est que topalov va l'inversé le schéma
c'est lui qui va finalement lâché des
pions pour l'activité
parce que là c'est les blogs comptes de
l'activité contre le pion en fait face
dont il voyait plus depuis l'arrivée de
paiement et la liquidation la paire de
faire de fronton la paire de funa fou et
cinq tours d2 voilà et là il ya un
problème sur des quatre là on le voit
bien là aussi - mais qui est un problème
par les plans des cadres il ya toujours
pion aux deux c ça serait qu'un des
changes mais en laissant ses gains et
charles oui mais très vite on peut jouer
en f1 donc tour c6 donc là évidemment il
des tours c6 basse est doublé les tours
et puis bon ben voilà c'est ça forcera
les blancs à on peut pas et on fait ce
qu'elle fout donc c'est un problème on
peut revenir là tout de suite ce qui
permettrait d'échanger les tours on
pourrait on pour et donc il joue b4
simplement 2004 alors b4 alors les
blancs peuvent pas laisser non parce que
là on est sur noir et donc on est
totalement opposé au fou et ça ça
consoliderait la position des blancs à
cette colonne serait bouché il y aurait
plus qu'à mettre la pression sur le pion
des et et on le croit que ses pions en
fait à ce travail est très fort là et si
on laisse ce donc il faut pas laisser
s'installer ici
d'ailleurs regardez tous les coups qui
suivent après la prime est roi et noir n
empêche que les blancs jouent b4 il
souhaiterait folk et bien c'est simple
parce qu'après b4 même les 4es pas
attaquable une tour à 1,8 pour être pas
venir à 4 cause du québec donc c'est une
structure saha contrefout blanquer
magnifique puisque le cavalier pro
contrôle plein casse blanchi les
surclassements a complètement
inattaquable et c'est une pièce qui
bloque ses allées magnifique ste pietri
donc on peut vraiment pas laissé faire
oui peut-être à premier abord issad
c'est bien ça paraît bizarre parce que
il ya un pion tient aux prises et on met
on met le pion jouait face poète remet
en venant d'en pêcher b4 on veut
chez un blocage ici qui serait favorable
aux blancs mais on ne peut pas on peut
pas tolérer b4 parce que le cavalier
seul
et puis on voit bien qu'on va prendre
deux avec une tour sur la deuxième donc
ça y est c'est l'inversé que tout à
l'heure on voulait pénétrer milieu blanc
sur la 7e hélas il est noir mais
n'arriva pas une structure deuxième
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui va se passer on
va le voir mais ça à compans même un peu
moins donc faut pas hésiter à prendre
l'initiative pour un pion l'erreur s'est
accroché au matériel finale toujours oui
oui mais oui oui là parce qu'il a
toujours c'est assez simple c'est si on
laisse faire les bécasses par les blancs
le cavalier monstrueux et il ya égalité
matérielle et un avantage positionnelle
où les les blancs vont pouvoir torturé
l'adversaire alors que là on va voir
tout reprendre les cas donc tout
reprendre 2 et voilà vraiment active
c'est pénible cette tour là sur la
deuxième on va voir c'est même très très
pénible puisque après tout reprendre mes
quatre fous h3 et là les landes
enfin topalov met l'accent sur le
problème des blancs c'est que le roi
regardez là le fameux fous géniaux qui
s'est échangé to b les voiliers comini
manque la même en finale b voici presque
matt s'est heureusement qu'à la torsion
ici la menace des noirs c'est prendre
dans ces cinq puisque surtout repenser 5
et la tomate du couloir grâce au fond
donc danger donc on voit comment topalov
a donné un pion pour l'activité que
fernand le b to b c4 alors là il a
espoir nombre de jouets b4 b5 très vite
mais regardez topalov ne se prend pas la
tête il n'a pas peur il joue simplement
tour des six et bien il veut venir en
des deux attaquants ici menaçant des
maths il faudra comment on protège parce
qu'on peut même pas venir c'est la cause
du fou moi je pense qu'il ya plein de
raisons aux retours des six déjà si on
revient la position juste avant quand la
tour a lancé six bons c'est certes au
noir de jouer mais en plus cela la
menace des parts de saab et 4 1 mais pas
seulement je pense que je pensais aussi
que ce roi et qui joue pas c'est
toujours ça ruinerait allée des
trois-quarts aile il a envie d'avaler
rester bien sûr on peut aussi je vais
calais de 30
et si les tours s'échange là dans cette
position là on prend du plomb avec un
détour qui protège le pian qui fit part
derrière important dans la tour derrière
exactement et ont bien f4 fourchette
temps fou aussi donc c'est vrai que
c'est pénible dans le tour des six
empêche cette manoeuvre est donc amené
des trois il n'est plus autorisé
voilà donc la halle 1 2 mais voit le
problème des tours qui ce qui se
doublent sur la deuxième il propose un
échange de tours ayant ça l'arrangerait
parce que là c'est assez pénible cette
configuration bien sûr leur taux peuvent
aucune raison qu'il a il à l'activité
pour voilà voilà il à l'activité dont
vers les viandes et de rares déclare la
torre forte non seulement continuer
l'action elle menace de doubler ici et
en plus elle fait pression sur b3 qui
fait que cali peut pas bouger
alors oui oui en plus bon là il ya des
thèmes mais je pense pas que ça serve à
grand chose dont on a pu s'ils jouaient
tour ces deux aussi tombé 2 puisque le
la tour ne peut pas ne peut pas prendre
ah oui on aurait pu jouer tour c'est
bien sûr qu'ils jouent et or c est
pourquoi il joue pas tant ces deux
probablement à barstow c4 parce que soi
c'est pénible aurait on revient revenus
ou même tout regret il aurait fallu
revenir ici il ya rien de spécial
aérienne spéciale donc tourbe et de sa
part est plus en forme en attaque mais
il faut être à 100 donc là on est quand
même bon en fait une activité le
regardez d'ailleurs les blancs
reviennent ici en défense parce que là
pourquoi il revient c'est un coup c'est
un coin il aurait toujours autre chose
ils auraient pu tenter de jouer de bk
puisque le pion ont été protégés par la
tour alors le problème est dense et le
prochain coup des noirs donc on valoir à
son tour eu un ici tour des des deux
voilà alors là ça y est boom comment on
fait une autre cour plutôt que tout re
c'était peut-être mais il ya une pièce
qui nous embête beaucoup beaucoup côté
blanc cette foule a pu commencer par
essayer de chasser au journal a essayé
de jouer tout racheter à tout à fait
tord h théâtre bien sûr mais la tour ces
deux et on peut pas revenir avec la tour
et aux menaces matt si les blancs
prennent il ya maths et il ya le
cavalier c5 qui ont les reins oui alors
c'est vrai que là il ya peut-être alors
mais julie qui joue qui joue pour le
gain d'à c'est la question franchement
non mais ce sont les blancs qui pour le
gain à cause de leur paye en plus de
l'activité des noirs est trop forte
ben c'est l'activité dès lors être
effectivement là si on fait ça
les noirs ont tout de suite une nulle
entraîneur soit il revient dans ces
quatre ce qui est une possibilité mais
ces quatre ça va pas du tout aller oui
non c'est cette bourse est clairement
l'activité contre le pion est ce que les
noirs ont aidé en fait directement une
nulle parce qu'on peut bouger la tour
alors ici on every two mais en fait on
peut en fait on peut on peut tout
simplement pour chasser la tour partout
où l on peut même prendre c'est certes
puisque si après ton prince croire dès
la tour est hors jeu donc simplement on
va kobe le pion oui oui mais pas le
protéger qu'une fois en double c'est
fini voilà cette tour est en jeu mais je
voulais juste donner une variable +
c'était juste on met toujours un tour en
face de l'autre le tour qui peut jamais
prendre à cause du mas du couloir et on
a une espèce de perpétuels dr eu un don
qui veut pas il veut pas éloigner sa
tour tour d2 donc l'attention menace
pourquoi me est lassé des tensions parce
qu'il ya des combines de matin tout
simplement imaginer que les blancs
jouent
donnez-vous bidon on veut dire f4v
quatre décès maths on reprend avec 2
c'est fini
voici tout simplement mode c'était
influent fini amat après bessin ont fait
tour échec par exemple
pour agen tour prend un échec roger un
tour échec à et la tour étant protégé
ici par le fou on peut jouer torch un
match donc c'est un math
dangereux donc il faut faire quelque
chose et heureusement il ya un coup
parce que s'il n'y en a pas c'est le
seul coup cavalier ou quatre chevaux
quand même pas se tromper
cavalli attaque la tour et ouf otage le
plan ne souffre t la tour des quatre
caves a laissé cinq tours d2 la
répétition de coups et il tente autre
chose
voilà donc la fessée de gagner donc on
voit bien que c'est les noirs qui
signifie pour les effets du vent ils
sont mieux livres ont récupéré leurs
pions sans problème un tour bien et
récupère le pion et après camel et des
deux tours b 4 simplement ici c'est une
finale on va quand même là déroulé parce
qu'elle est allée quand même simple
regardez ouais m'enfin là là on dit
souvent mon le full support aux
cavaliers mais quand l'un des pions des
deux côtés là les pions sont du même
côté et l'avantagent du fou ça leur
pièce longue portée ne joue pas en fait
parce que le
le cavalier quand même une pièce
puissante
oui mais il ya davantage de l'espace
aussi pour la wii enfin y'a pas y a pas
de quoi gagner la partie
d'ailleurs voilà ça finit assez vite ici
tour ces deux arrivées que les pétitions
de position c'est pas suffisant
évidemment avec les pions du même côté
bon au final technique jeu beau cavalier
beau ballet de cavale et on secoue on
secoue de cavaillé moi j'ai pas souvenir
d'avoir vu un peu partout dans je sais
plus le nom d'année 13 au trésor
comprendre il faut qu'on les revoie on
va recompter le nombre de coups de
cavaliers pour finir donc cette
commensaux alors ça commence
21 ans va dérouler 21e 22e
on va dérouler tak tak voilà un deux
trois quatre deuxièmes cavaliers qui
veut bouger
cinq six sept huit neuf attaques la tour
10 11 12 12 coups de cavaliers de suite
si un record en lumière encore derrière
à 13
oui c'est vrai là c'est fini voilà
dernier coup le coup deux tours le 35
croisée 2 donc tour des deux parents le
13 13 coût de cavaliers je n'ai pas
souvenir d'une partition de l'eau du
monde avait treize coups de coeur et de
suite moins d'une partie du court ces
superbes donc rien pour ça c'est deux
parties il mérite d'être retenu grâce à
ce bal qu'ailleurs moi j'ai cru en
suivant la partie on dirait que tu dis
est en train de rendre fou c'était les
cavaliers fou
face à topalov mais non au total of n'a
pas n'a pas craqué bon c'était pas
évident de trouver des de trouver des
plans oui on sait ce n'est pas très
clair qui avait l'avantagé on a donc on
a vu topalov un départ il gagne la paire
de fou il ya début on a vu plusieurs
situations où il peut prendre un café en
c6 récupérer un pur en e2 voilà un pion
plus il y avait des contrôles mana faut
voir là il faudrait analyser plus
précisément la variante avec tours à
huit qui oui cette fameuse marien
effectivement là qu'on peut revoir
d'ailleurs les allées pas loin elle est
simplement voilà ici
voilà le foot en a 5 voilà sur calais à
celle de jouer ici tour à 8
c'est ce que tu proposes est peut-être
un peu plus précis et sur canal et ses 6
on prend et là tu penses que topalov
aurait pu le tenter de prendre
l'avantagé avec tout reprendre de avec
la différence à la police et que à si
ses protégés et que le x 5 contrôle ce
qui change beaucoup de choses parce
qu'on peut jouer tour d2 et il n'ya pas
l'astuce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure avec
le roi f1 là je ne sais pas ce qu'il
faut jouer mais pas évident tout à fait
et on met lass pour des 2 avec ben laden
que les noirs sont un peu mieux bon
maintenant c'est peut-être pas suffisant
non qu'ils auraient davantage on disait
que les noirs et être un petit plus puis
le moment où ça s'est un peu retourné où
les blancs us et oui et topalov a joué
le bon coup b4 qui donne un pion ouais
mais qui prend beaucoup d'acquis voilà
qui prend un ticket donne un client mais
qui empêche les blindes de consolider
leurs cavaliers et voilà donc belle
partie dans le camp mais alors c'était
la sixième c'est bon c'est quand une
bonne opération pour lui puisqu'il mène
toujours d'un point et la 7e il y aura
de nouveau les blancs donc
il est bien mis match un point d'avancé
il risque aussi partie on peut dire que
là le favori mais non c'est un an je
crois que ton alors si on joue pour
revenir au score c'est celui qu'ils ont
est forcément oui c'est bien sûr elle
met topaloff est quand même chez lui en
bulgarie donc ça peut aussi l'aider à
prendre confiance
il a des supporters il y aura bien sûr
l'avantagé de jouer chez lui donc
d'avoir ses repères et ça pourrait ça
pourrait jouer contre à nantes
il faut qu'il fasse gaffe à la bouffe
bulgare peut-être je vous lis est parti
j'ai l'impression que c'est une des
premières parties où il n'a pas été
complètement dominés par à nantes dans
le milieu de jeu c'est à dire sur la sur
sa première défaite blanche annonce
n'avait pas grand-chose de sortie de
l'ouverture il a vraiment dominé milieu
de jeu et là c'est pas été guère
finalement si je pense que c'est les
noirs qui ont toujours la meilleure
chance in fine et dans dans cette partie
là ouais c'est possible possible il n'a
pas réussi à attirer bénéfice est de
cette position donc tout palop n'est
loin d'être mort il gigote encore gigote
encore une belle suite une belle suite
merci dont la course est à participation
à des vandales tv on te dit une
prochaine fois
puis sur une prochaine fois on sait que
tu es un fan de l'émission et
mais moi je me suis je vous donne rendez
vous pour la suite de ce championnat du
monde et dans les prochaines parties on
devrait avoir la visite
de nicolas magic giffard voilà merci a
bientot avoir bonne soirée